[Applause]  [Music]   [Applause] [Music]  really know how to work a carpet there  that's always a good one when you got a  big ass ponytail like this that's a good  Sofia tonight and what what an assassin  would wear to a premiere I thought this  was it you want to kill burrata if  you're not gonna kill him he is gonna  kill you and then probably meet two for  walking you up in there and when  Halley's not working what she wants is  quality time with her kids  they better be planning something big  that's what I got to say because  Mother's Day is the only holiday I  really care about  it's the only day where we get to you  know have our kids tell us and show us  how much they love us most of the years  pretty thankless job and that day I'm  like just yeah give it all to me give it  a give it give it give it and they do  and so it's great  [Music]